I interviewed and met with four
potential
justices of our great Supreme Court they
are outstanding people and they are
really incredible people in so many
different ways very interesting though
was my four meetings will be meeting
with two or three more and we'll make a
decision on the United States Supreme
Court the new justice I think the person
that is chosen will be outstanding and
to buttress his point the president sent
out this tweet to his 45 million Twitter
followers he writes a big week
especially with our numerous victories
in the Supreme Court heading back to the
White House now focus will be on the
selection of a new Supreme Court justice
exciting times for our country economy
may be stronger than it has ever been
we were just well let's bring in our
panel Tom Rogan is commentary writer for
the Washington Examiner Molly Hemingway
senior editor at The Federalist at
Charles Lane an opinion writer for The
Washington Post I was getting ahead of
myself myself bringing you in before
actually introducing you Molly we're
talking with britt hume about this
upcoming court pick it is certainly
going to be a very heated battle yeah
past is prologue it will be very
contentious it's also true that it's a
very tough time for democrats to be
fighting this pick a lot of people are
focusing on how republicans might peel
away but if you have a bunch of senators
in red states in states that were
carried by donald trump who are
democrats fighting for their political
lives and if they throw up a lot of
obstruction here that could be very
tough for them in what are already some
tough races that they are facing
you know Donnelly height camp Manchin
McCaskill so there are quite a few
senators there that are in a very tough
spot there's also the issue that if they
do vote to obstruct this nominee and if
the Republicans can't keep their
coalition together that only
incentivizes Republicans to show up and
vote in November to make sure that the
next process that will go much smoother
for the Republican as if to make the
point the president invited
many of those senators or conferred with
them at the White House about this
choice I think what you're seeing here
is once upon a time some of us remember
the gang of 14 on federal judges which
was a bipartisan coalition that was
trying to steer that crazy and
contentious process down the middle a
little bit now it's sort of shrunk to
the gang of five you have Murkowski and
collins for republicans and then the
three Democrats Heitkamp
Manchin and Donnelly visited the
president you get the feeling those five
are trying to help each other out
because they all kind of had the same
interest which is not having to vote on
a candidate that will cause them
embarrassment in the fall and when Susan
Collins said what she said about Roe
versus Wade I really heard her saying
don't send me somebody up here who who's
gonna jam me and embarrass me and force
me into a tough vote on that issue of
precedent and Roe versus Wade and of
course I think that's probably what
Senator McConnell would prefer to to
keep to just do this on the basis of
Republican votes we'll see what the
White House what kind of response she's
gonna get out of the White House on that
but for instance a couple of the names
that are considered frontrunners on the
president's list this time around were
also on the list when he nominated and
successfully placed Neal Gorsuch on the
bench and one of the opportunities the
president has here is that it's both the
best way that he can unify the
Republican Party around him is that as
the leader and also the banner man now
right that there is a sense of unity
with tax cuts but also with with the
appointment of well-regarded justices
and Nield Gorsuch obviously very much
respected really across the judicial
spectrum including by liberals who
oppose him on certain issues and I think
you see as well the president tried to
take that narrative forwards with these
selectees who again are respected and to
try and push Democrats into that
position of do they challenge him and
risk their own position in those Senate
seats or and this is where Trump has the
opportunity or did they vote with him
and then put themselves into it you know
it goes into the fueling inside the
Democratic Party and we see obviously
with Cortes or cassia right that the the
new wave of Democrats who want to lead
that momentum forwards to the next
presidential election you can create
this warfare in the party even if you
sort of leave so you said Trump is in a
strong position I think yeah and well
and and and you echo something that the
President himself said we're about to
play that sound he's looking out there
at the political landscape and you know
despite his poll numbers he thinks he's
in a very good place listen to what he
told Maria Bartiromo
between Maxine Waters and Nancy Pelosi
and getting rid of vice and having open
borders and the biggest thing you have
open borders all that's gonna do is lead
to massive massive crime that's gonna be
their platform open borders which equals
crime I think they'll never win another
election so I'm actually quite happy
about do you share the president's
belief on that Molly never you should
never predict too far out in advance but
you have a problem again with the
Democratic Party a lot of people have
invested in just resistance at all costs
obstructing everything the people who
have not done that who actually are
running on an agenda are extremely to
the left of the mainstream of the
American public and so it'll be
difficult to have that message such as
the one that won the day in the primary
in New York of democratic socialism that
is not going to resonate quite as much
in tougher districts and so it is it is
a challenging moment for Democrats but
they both of the approaches they've
taken have problems both obstruction and
far left and senators like Amy Klobuchar
have said you can't get rid of ice
what's going on here is fascinating
which is that in some ways the base of
the party is running away from its
leadership in Washington Chuck Schumer
would never have chosen the message
abolish ice he never would have chosen
the message it's a democratic socialism
but the voters out in Queens those who
showed up they chose it and this has got
a life of its own on social media it's
got a life of its own at the grassroots
way beyond the sort of perception of the
Senators and the leadership in the house
here in Washington I'm
sure they really know how to handle it
but to the president's delight that is
the issue that is making headlines this
week yeah I mean Democrats are stuck in
a in a difficult position in the sense
that as Charles says there is that
populist fervor towards this issue that
ice is immoral that it should be
decapitated but on the president's side
he truly believes and I think frankly
he's probably right that at the margin
of the general election contest which is
ultimately what matters it won't play
well to say get rid of law enforcement